would you ever find yourself so tired
that your comedy would shift meaner
what's a Conan that's suffering on
burnout look like when you're thrust
well everyone here in the room just
they're sorry to ask you guys
you're sitting with Stalin and his Pilot
Bureau
time when you get a little grumpy and
what's that look like and everyone else
bukarin Khrushchev and all these other
they're always happy always always great
he's a good guy
fun at party never kill my wife yeah
well one time but not second wife yet
maybe we'll certainly you can speak to
this excuse me I'm a master of passive
aggression and so
yeah I don't think I've ever seen anyone
do passive aggressiveness and so it's
it's weird because I've been told it can
be quite funny it's it's to get you know
I was raised you can't directly confront
anyone so I would never say like Nikki
you know you just screwed up and you're
in big trouble I would never do that why
wouldn't you ever do that because I just
don't come from that culture what's the
fear oh the fear is anger is toxic and
Truth is toxic yes so um when I was
younger or even into my teen years and
early 20s if I said something kind of
like truthful around my parents my mom
would be like don't be mean like that's
mean the truth is the truth is me so
what happens is I think we hyper develop
uh this is my breakdown every culture
has their way of doing it but I think
one of the reasons that Irish
people are funny is because it's all
they'll allow themselves at least the
branch I come from we're not the type to
say hey I I really didn't appreciate
what you did in there that made me feel
this way and it wasn't a good feeling so
we need to talk about that that's the
last thing you would do now thank God I
met
uh Liza and we got married because very
early on she was like this thing you're
doing I'm not loving it what is it is
the real problem and I'd go
um well I was it was fun yeah it's kind
of funny but what is it really what's
really going on here and I'd go you ate
the last cupcake and you wanted that
cupcake is that what you then say I was
hoping that I could have that cupcake
wow I kind of was hoping I could have
that cupcake and um so anyway but she's
my wife she yeah she gets to uh she gets
to do that but that's scary to do even
before she's your wife because I have
the same thing where I think that I
can't ever say anything critical of
someone else because then they'll just
come back at me well you are this yes
and my biggest fear is you're ugly I
think that I my therapist is always like
because I think some boy in fifth grade
called me ugly if I because I had an
opinion about something he said to me
well you're ugly shut up you have buck
teeth and so now I I never ever
criticize anyone because I think they
can always pull that card or like the
meanest thing that maybe not it's not
ugly anymore but it's whatever I think
about myself that I think maybe other
people haven't caught on to if I find
out that they've seen that and they know
that then I'm done and and I'm so scared
in a romantic relationship and I'm doing
better at it in my own but in an early
stages of one confronting something and
having them say
you I always just think they're going to
say well that's the way I am so if you
don't like it then go and either I have
to put up with it and then I'm just the
one putting up with things or I have to
leave and I don't want to do that so
it's easier for me to just say nothing I
think the biggest thing that and I can
relate to what you're saying on this
because my issue is if I'm going to
confront someone I better be right and
my biggest nightmare is saying you know
if I you know said hey Nikki I just
don't like you've been on this podcast
three times and each time you've been on
the podcast you've done this thing and
you've already like yeah this is
hypothetical
I almost was gonna you know turn to
Gorly but it would probably be something
real
um yeah but I like you so much I can't
even manufacture it so what I'm saying
is yeah but you know you've come on the
podcast three times and each time you
did such and such you might then say to
me a Conan I've been on the podcast once
and and then I'm wrong and I would go
into what I think my people do is we
keep score quietly so I don't want to
confront you because what if you have a
really good comeback and I'm in it so
what I'll do is saying and I really it
really bugs me every time Nikki's on the
show she brings up the fact that you
know she saw my feet once and they're
hideous
I know I know and uh grotesque uh
grotesque features uh and I'm I just
really bugs me and I want to talk to her
about it instead I'll just like she did
it again I'm just gonna keep track I'm
going to mark this down and keep track
and then next time in some imagine
future I'll confront her now if when you
leave the room Gourley or Sona says
you know did you notice that I noticed
you got really tense at that one point I
would be happy to tell them so I am I'm
not happy with you and if they say well
walk out there and tell Nikki I'd be
like don't wait
she comes here she comes and so I think
that's how I used to be I've gotten a
lot better just chipping away through
you know therapy cognitive therapy
wanting to be different I think which is
the best thoughts yeah tracing the
thoughts I'm a big believer in in
cognitive therapy because it's so
logical which is when you're panicking
write down on a sheet on a legal pad
what is it you're afraid will happen and
then one of the things you'll write down
is well I'm afraid that this person will
say that I'm ugly and in that moment
that feels real to you walk away 20
minutes later come back look at the list
of things that you're really afraid and
you're going to say
those are those things are going to look
stupid to you yeah you're going to say
I'm not ugly I'm mostly a very
attractive person so that's just stupid
once you're removed from the thought for
25 30 minutes and then you see it
written down on on paper you see how
empty it is you know I'm afraid Conan
won't speak to me well no that's he's
not like that that's not going to happen
I mean actually it could
now and guess what you are right on the
edge but no I'm afraid I wish
girly keeps trying to get back damn it I
called him a dirty rotten Nick he still
has me back
um no but anyway interesting looking at
those thoughts leaving are you just
leaving this this list of things out
around your house
average yeah
sometimes I want people to find them so
I write down fake yes
I'm too good a lover
my penis is too big and hoping that
people will find it and go oh you
shouldn't be here
yeah I I think that that's that's a good
that's a good way to looking at the
thought looking back on it how
ridiculous it is because I know this all
sounds ridiculous and all these these
fears I have but it is interesting to um
be so scared of Confrontation and so
scared to stand up for yourself unless
you know you're right which is why I
like I really enjoy being vegan because
I just know I'm it's the only thing I'm
sure about I'm right about and it's just
and I don't get I'm not like one of
these people that will make you feel bad
about eating meat I'm not like that but
I it is the one thing the only thing
maybe I'm certain of that I'm right
about I am that's why I like I only eat
meat that committed a crime like great
yeah I I there's a place as a service
that will get yes a cow that trampled
someone
a pig that attacked a dog and and so
they're they're tried a fair trial I may
have representation and then they're
murdered oh I would like that yeah
I love eggs
um those are a little tricky because
what did the uh unborn egg do yeah but
um I believe life begins at hatching so
sometimes I think
maybe the the animal that we are eating
eight animals in a past life yeah that's
paying for it no my way because I do
love uh I love eating I'm a meat eater
so I just I am very good at coming and
very imaginative at coming up with
horrible things that uh that cow did
good that entitled me to this wonderful
steak yeah and that works fine for me
all of your all the cows you eat are
Hitler
and conversely I look at a salad and go
that salad's done too much good in this
one I can't take it out oh my God yeah
yeah I must set it free yes he's always
setting his salads free in the
wilderness and he doesn't understand
that they can't go anywhere
go solid go live your own life one day
though like three rage salads yeah